yes all wrinkled in time and hurricane
heist back-to-back but only one of those
movies has someone flinging hubcaps
during a hurricane that are buzzing into
people like buzz saws we're talking
about that movies let's do that
[Music]
hurricane ice so hurricane high Stars
Toby Kebbell and Maggie Gray's here's
the premise if you didn't see the
trailer there is this government
facility with a lot of money there are
people who want to break into this place
steal all the money and just for a
cherry on top it's happening during a
hurricane like the biggest hurricane
ever because why not now Maggie Grace
and Toby Kebbell there's only two that
stand in their way
in strict hold on who directed this I
know that work I just don't know
it's actually the hurricane heist rob
coen that's like if you have a 90s
guilty-pleasure movie that's not so good
but you enjoy it it might just be one of
his movies so for the cast I meet Toby
Kebbell or is a little weird to hear him
talk like a robber got to do this hair
we got shave that their money gonna save
the money cuz I'm two cables have time
it's strange no matter how you slice it
that's weird but that dude has got to be
the most talented guy with the worst
agent ever like is this agent drunk 78
percent of the time has to be what is
he's a weatherman who's fighting
terrorists or heists people they're not
so terrible the their decks or worse
people out there but what I just
appreciated about this movie is it
committed to its absurdity this movie
knows what it is I can't fault a movie
for that I can only ever praise a movie
for that but I found myself morbidly if
not absurdly enjoying my time in this
movie simply put if for nothing else if
you just block out this refuge remember
this part it's a better die hard movie
than the last die hard movie then again
the Superman game for Nintendo 64 is a
better die hard movie than the last die
hard movie hurricane heist isn't as good
as Olympus has fallen but it's better
than London has fallen it's like some
weird part in between not better CGI's
movie has a lot of CGI because there's a
storm happening and at no point are they
like alright we can't actually have
principal photography for this fictional
film until a hurricane happens there's
gonna be some effects happening a lot of
times you're like yeah those are
made-for-tv effects let's see a
particular getting sucked in the air and
they're dangling on ropes my god there's
a certain stupidest the movie is I found
myself actually enjoying the part where
they're bonding over PB&J sandwiches I
enjoyed the fact that the villain though
he does overcook it a bit and he's kind
liam neeson ish but Maggie Grace played
Liam Neeson's daughter and taken I'm
sure they were like well that's a little
weird let's get Liam Neeson and he over
cooks it a bit but I did like the
progression of the fact that he did that
he didn't want to kill anybody he just
wanted the money but as things start
going a rides you know slowly he's like
I'm cool with death it always cracks me
up in a movie like this though a beast
or more not the fact is these people
want money so just you know people are
probably gonna die if you resist him
give him the money there will be another
time sure they'll get caught a digital
Wonderland we live in I really doubt
they're gonna get far I suppose that
logic hit anybody we wouldn't have a
movie pretty cool anyone at the movie
does drag on a bit too much it's a bit
too long which is funny because it's
only about an hour and a half long so
when an hour and a half long movie is a
bit too long maybe it should have just
been a made-for-tv movie certainly looks
like it has the budget for it I'm
putting this in my guilty pleasure slot
belt I do feel like this movie can be
enjoyable enough with the right blood
alcohol content that's me saying is
enjoyable if you're drunk
ya know it's a birdie movie abruptly and
stealing is funny how quickly it ends
only death Proof by Quentin Tarantino
has a more abrupt ending than hurricane
heist ugh yeah I love me some good
cheese alright so hurricane hi Simon not
promising anything but hey you know you
you know if you would like it but have
you seen it what did you think about it
what's your favorite guilty pleasure
and/or disaster movie whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you
[Music]